habt ihr schon mal gefragt was das
allererste minecraft video war was
überhaupt auf youtube hochgeladen gibt
bücher meine liebe freude jacob zu einer
weiteren folge der micro facts ich habe
mir wieder fünf cool effect rausgesucht
und ich würde auch sagen wir fangen
direkt an nachdem ich euch eine kleine
neuerungen vorgestellt und zwar habe ich
gesehen dass das immer mehr leute machen
um umfragen zu benutzen oder wir haben
das auch untereinander in skype konfis
wenn wir irgendwas plan oder so und zwar
diese google documents deswegen habe ich
und in der beschreibung einen link
eingefügt wo ihr mir die fag zusenden
können weil über mail ist das immer so
mein speichers irgendwann voll von
google mail
und da habe ich nicht so tollen
überblick deswegen und ein formular
müsst euch nicht mehr info anmelden ihr
müsst ihr nur eure namen eingeben oder
ob der anonym bleiben wollte einfach als
einfach draufklicken ihr seht unten oben
in der beschreibung ingo eingeblendet
und da könnt ihr mir perfekt zu sein
also bitte nutzt das und jetzt bei mir
im endeffekt numero uno ein stammt aus
dem minecraft forum allgemein nämlich in
den nächsten vier folgen immer recht
viele fakes aus dem minecraft nicht
forum sondern wiki weil ich am
vorproduzieren bin und dann immer die
ganzen mails durchgehen und so dass es
im forum einfach wiki einfach ein
bisschen leid da man was not mit mir und
zwar besagt der erste effekt es
existiert eine textur für pferde mit
ruhe die mbt variable testen horse
erlaubt es mit hohem ausgestattete
werden das spiel einzufügen und jetzt
denkt man sich erstmal auf dem esel oder
auf dem donkey oder ob im auto oder das
ist glaube ich das gleiche sogar ist ja
auch egal jedenfalls kann man da über
altran anbringen pferde allerdings nicht
weil das irgendwie zu op ist oder so und
da geht das jetzt mit einem 1 1
allerdings geht das mit diesem befehl
sammeln entity horse drei wellen type-0
gäste das doppel
ich drücke jetzt einfach mal enter und
dann seht ihr schon hier ist so ein
pferd das kann ich jetzt auch reiten
wenn ich möchte und ich kann auch okay
das mag mich jetzt nicht aber ich will
euch auch gar nicht zeigen was passiert
wenn ich versuche das inventar zu öffnen
weil
dann stürzt das spiel ab im wege steht
wenn man jedoch auf dem pferd sitzen
das inventar öffnet schließt sich
minecraft dass das pferde inventar nicht
darstellen kann also es kann zwar diese
textur darstellen weil es ja beim donkey
und bei myspace und bei maultier ist es
ja so ähnlich mit den mit den mit den
kisten allerdings geht das halt bei
pferden nur mit diesem befehl das ist
ein jested horses und sonst einmal
darauf zugreifen will stützer spiel hat
das möchte ich euch ehrlich gesagt nicht
zeigen weil dann halt mein spiel
abstützt aber das war auf jeden fall
fact nummer eins und hierzu ein
komisches regen mich macht das jetzt der
nächste feld ist wieder aus dem
minecraft wifi und zwar ist es wieder
richten fehlen uns mal mit befehlen kann
man richtigen meist machen
übrigens habe ich mein letztes die idee
gehabt was haltet ihr davon wenn ich mal
ein video mache minecraft commands also
ich hab in minecraft so lustige sagt
minecraft vorgestellt werden und
minecraft commands dann einfach weil mir
aufgefallen ist bei facts wer hat mir
echt immer extrem viele romands auch so
zugesetzt sohn geht martin und den
commander passiert was total witziges
denn dann würde ich einfach so eine
kleine serie nebenher machen wir schauen
mit ihren ankommt gegen die minecraft
commands hier mir dann auch zu senden
könnt also zeigt es gibt einfach mal den
daumen hoch oder schreibt irgendwie
kommentare oder wie auch immer das
zeigen wollte ob ihr sonne minecraft
commands folge haben wollte weil ich
hätte auf jeden fall mega rock pop und
auch richtig viel potenzial schon an
kommentaren und commerce vorhanden
jedenfalls gebe ich beim nächsten fact
einfach mal diesen command einsamen
zombie drei wellen in wolle rebell
doppelpunkt 1 raiding entity horst teig
vierte mainz und ihr seht schon
beherrschen zombie und er wird vom fährt
runter geschnitten
jedenfalls sagt dass minecraft forum mit
dem befehl die befehle mit dem befehl
kann man einen zombie reitet auf einem
zombie fährt erschaffen er ist jedoch
unbesiegbar wenn ich das ganze jetzt
allerdings mal ein gebe es schon der
wird relativ schnell vom pferd
runtergeschmissen und das pferd ist ein
richtiges zombie fährt weil die
dingsbums da schon ein bischen kacke ist
der command ist ein bisschen ausgereizt
man kann allerdings mit diesen commands
halt was ihr euch damit zeigen wollte
einfach alles mögliche erschaffen und
deswegen weiß ich nicht also ich hätte
indes es halt einfach bei den fans
werden wir mega viele sachen zugesendet
die okay jetzt kann ich die natürlich
umging das ist klar weil er nicht auf
dem verbreitet ist aber wenn ihr mal
ganz schnell schauen wenn ich hier zu
machen und hier wenn ich dann so
drauflos und so junge
auch jetzt ist er wieder runter
jedenfalls wenn auf den zombie fans pont
ist dazu er ist eigentlich um das jetzt
mal wieder eine ganz simple sache die
eigentlich glaube ich sogar jedem schon
aufgefallen ist aber der sinn ist mir
irgendwie immer noch nicht so richtig im
gedächtnis geblieben und zwar habe ich
ja hier schnee in der hand und ganz
normalen schnee und wenn ich jetzt
jemand normalen blocken setzt auf den
schnee dann ist sie als normaler block
und ich kann natürlich auch den normalen
schnee zusammen blog stapeln allerdings
schaut mal was passiert wenn ich hier
einen schnee drauf setzte somit
rechtswegen wenn ich hier recht geglaubt
mache passiert nichts ich kann nicht auf
den schon hoch gesteckten schnee der
genau die gleiche höhe ist genau die
gleiche text du alles gleich kann ich
nicht noch eins drauf packen allerdings
auf dem anderen schnee kann ich das noch
machen
und wenn ich jetzt hier wieder auf der
höhe hoch gesteckt bin jetzt wieder
nicht jetzt setzt sich wieder normal
schnee drauf und jetzt jetzt kann ich
halt drauf setzte gesehen also ich jetzt
hier so einen drauf ein ganzen da kann
ich dann draufsetzen
wenn ich allerdings schon hoch
gesteckten was dort sitzen will dann
geht's nicht wenn ihr wisst warum ich
verstehe dass allgemein nicht mehr dem
fucking schnell schnell schnell aber wir
sollten eigentlich mal den real läuft
jetzt in deutschland ein bisschen schnee
haben finde ich aber dass auf jeden fall
fällt nur drei und der bezug von charlie
und zwar schreibt charlie charlie ist
das jetzt ich glaube das ist ein männer
name oder
wenn du den schwert bogen trick anwendet
aus der welt raus und wieder rein gehst
dennis aus dem schwert ein bogen
geworden das wollen wir natürlich direkt
mal testen ich packe ein schwert hin und
her in den bergen und jetzt klicke ich
hier auf die 1 jetzt ist das vertauschen
jetzt kann ich ja mit dem schwert pfeile
schießen ihr wisst dass ihr und jetzt
geh ich mal aus der welt raus speichern
und zurück zum menü so erzählt jedoch
einzelspieler christmas facts bin wieder
drin und ihr seht schon ich habe zwei
bogen all bögen bogen keine ahnung
jedenfalls es hat sich dann jedenfalls
dazu verändert und ja ich weiß nicht
warum ist das nicht schon direkt sondern
erst so komisch rumbeck dass man dann
mit dem schwert um mit dem pferd mit dem
schwert auf einmal schießen kann man
merkt es war ja lange paroli luca
jedenfalls ist das fact nummer vier und
dank goalie nummer 5 ist wieder etwas
was sie gerade eingeblendet und zwar
habt ihr schon mal gefragt was das
allererste minecraft video war was
überhaupt auf youtube hochladen gibt
weil es gibt soviel minecraft videos auf
youtube und man denkt sie hat damit
angefangen
es war dort schon zwar sollte minecraft
ganz zu anfang cave game heißen die
anderen wissen dass noch damals
umbenannt in minecraft progress und das
war das erste minecraft video das erste
video war quasi dieses game savegame
text und das andere war minecraft
progressed an das ist vor fünf jahren
hochladen wurden von j auf seinem kanal
der ist glaube ich nicht neu sondern
seit youtube kanal erst habe ich ein
bisschen anders irgendwie jedenfalls
sind das die ersten minecraft videos die
hochgeladen wurden und das ist auf jeden
fall interessanter effekt dass das ganze
schon fünf jahre lang existiert damit
würde ich allerdings sagen meine lieben
freunde ich hoffe dass euch diese folge
micro facts gefallen hat sorry das ist
alles müssen miteinander ist die
nächsten folgen und allen videos in den
nächsten zwei wochen werden auch so ein
bisschen crazy sein weil ich das jetzt
alles innerhalb von drei tagen vor
produzieren muss ich hoffe ich kriege
das hin es wird wahrscheinlich drei
schlaflose nächte noch werden aber
trotzdem eine serie wollt wo ich die
commands vorstelle dann zeigt damit eine
bewertung oder schreibt sie jetzt in das
formular eintragen das steht auch in der
beschreibung und dann sehen wir uns wann
das wieder los